In this lesson I've covered distributed shared memory
and particularly I've given you a specific example
of a distributed shared memory system called Treadmarks
that uses lazy release consistency and multiple writer
coherence. I just want to leave you with
some thoughts about non-page based DSM systems before
concluding this lesson. There have been systems that
have been built that do not use granularity
of a page for coherence maintenance. I
mentioned earlier that if you want to maintain
granularity not at the page level, then you
have to track individual reads and writes that
is happening on a thread. So one approach is what is called a library based
approach. Here the idea is that, the programming
framework, the programming library, is going to give
you a way by which you can annotate
shared variables that you're going to use in your
program. Whenever you touch a shared variable part of
creating the executable is to cause a trap at
the point of access to the shared variable
so that the DSM software will be contacted, and
the DSM software can then take the coherence action
at the point of access to that shared variable.
So, in this case, there is no operating
system support needed because in the binary itself
we are making sure that at the point of access we're going to result in a trap
that will get us into the trap handler that is part of DSM software so that it
can take the coherence actions. And examples of
systems that use this mechanism include Shasta, that was
done at Digital Equipment Corporation, and Beehive which
was done at Georgia Tech. And because we
are doing this sharing at the level of
variables, you don't have any fault sharing which
is possible with page based systems and single
write or cache coherence protocol. So once the
DSM software takes the coherence action, which might
include fetching the data that is associated with the
variable you are trying to access, then the
DSM software can resume this thread that caused
this trap in the first place. Another approach
to providing shared abstractions is not at the level
of memory locations, but at the level of
structures that are meaningful for an application. And,
this is what is called structured DSM. So,
the idea is that there is a programming library
which actually provides abstractions that can be
manipulated in an application program. And the
abstractions can be manipulated using API calls
that are part of the language runtime. So
when the application makes the API call,
at that point, when an application makes those
API calls that point, the language runtime
gets into gear and says what coherence actions
do I need to make in order to satisfy
this API call. All of those coherence actions are going
to be taken at the point of that API
call, and that might include fetching data from a remote
node in the cluster. And once the semantics of
that API call have been executed by the language runtime,
then it's going to resume this thread that made
the call in the first place. Again, there is no
OS support needed for this. And the structured DSM is a very popular approach
that has been used in systems such as Linda, Orca, and Stampede that was done at
Georgia Tech, and successors to Stampede called
Stampede RT and, and PTS. And in this
course later on, we're going to see PTS
as an example of a structured DSM system.